I'm gonna have someone sub for me for a
second okay Marshawn are you doing
Cipriani if you played doom before yeah
I need to come put a demo down right
quick
yeah let's go let's play Doom I like
your hat Marshawn it looks good I'm like
y'all hey we're trying to get him one of
them yeah um well oh yeah man what's the
word I'm not going I'm a curfew motion
are you doing I was going to put it on a
different game that's that's another
game I gotta tell you about that game
when we get off camera we see new stuff
yeah you get up close and personal no
what's that who's that guy it don't
matter he's getting pushed marks on you
now at your whole life like this I mean
you like drive along and go on drive it
now and hey man I seen you on the ride
alone
yeah I'm trying to stab my dad he was
riding with the dices though I wanted to
I didn't know what was going on I don't
know what they were smoking told me they
told me they knew he was gonna be out
here for the Superbowl so if you come
through opening your street passes
accept it really I got street cred in
Oakland no yeah you come with me Nate
you saw it though got this hat no one's
gonna mess with me that's for sure you
write everything so think you had stupid
it changed us fantastic it ghost over
though that's like a good men are no
good stupid you know you say a female
was bad yeah was she good but she's good
but sometimes you say she's bad and
she's just back and you're right then we
got other word for that
coughing on the play on the play what
did you do something in his mouth nope
I'm in the same way man that's when you
bring a mouth just want you even let me
pour take you got a different kind of
juice you want juice on big ok I'm
trying to get one of them has though you
want one of these put that right on top
I like that you like that yeah I don't
know what kind of look I got right now
you look like Donald Trump right now
yeah look I'm like money I'll take that
congratulations to my two Africans yes
yes sorry I actually toasted in on the
Africa maybe I'm an honorary
there you go
so I'm honorary let's do it myself
Africa for you baby South Africa
you